on
[Musique]
eh bien à part à l'automne si c'est
melissa maulin 18
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'une
campagne que vous avez peut-être vu
passer dans les médias sociaux qui est
le cas en sol canadien
quand selon le jour du canada en
prévision du 1er juillet journée les
célébrations nationales
cette campagne là elle vient d'une
mouvance du temps où une base sociale
novance des communautés et en réaction
extrêmement solide à la découverte des
215 enfants à camelot et je pense que ça
a été beaucoup nourrie aussi par le
manque de réactivité autour de la
découverte de ces corps autour de l'
espèce d'ignorance qu'ils existent sont
les pensionnats malgré le fait que il ya
13 ans on a fait des excuses nationales
monsieur après à l'époque on a eu la
commission denquête vérité
réconciliation et des sondages qui ont
été faites dernièrement montre que
seulement 20% de la population
canadienne sont au courant de l'histoire
ou ou même de l'existence des
pensionnats au canada
donc vous pouvez imaginer que pour les
communautés autochtones qui ont été
touchés par les pensionnats qui était
justement sous une évidence fédéral mais
aussi pour un vin scialytique à sion les
communautés autochtones
eh bien ce n'est pas une journée de
célébration le 1er juillet c'est une
journée que pour beaucoup de gens ils se
veulent être une journée de deuil
national
comme si on devrait vraiment prendre le
temps de s'arrêter
en tant que pays de dire cette année
nous faisons un deuil national pour tous
les enfants qui ont été découverts qui
seront découverts les survivants des
pensionnats d'une journée qui permet de
montrer que chaque enfant qu'on et c'est
malheureusement un peu ce qu'ils avaient
explique le nommer dernière chronique
que la campagne des gilets orange était
une fin qui avaient été déboutées par
une femme qui le premier jour de sa de
son arrivée dans un pensionnat portait
une chemise orange on lui avait arraché
on l'a dit on ne lui aurait jamais
redonné
cette chemise que sa grand mère avait
acheté et 10e c'est cette liaison avec
la couleur orange à toute une maison où
je me sentais pas important pas écouté
et donc le plus à perdre pour qu'il y
ait cette couleur là aussi pour ça que
la campagne c'est pour ça que vous voyez
peut-être ici beaucoup de deux photos de
profil orange sur bohain médias sociaux
mais présentement il ya un moment d'un
raid qui demande et pour certaines
personnes mais mieux vaut un moment de
dire qu' on ne peut pas célébrer le jour
du canada dans un concept de génocide
dans un concept de l'ignorance culturel
et moi je comprends j'entends la
résonance à travers les médias sociaux
qui viennent de l'ouest et ce qui est
plus difficile peut-être c'est quand on
habite au québec la signification du
jour du canada est absolument pas là
même où à montréal c'est une journée de
déménagement ont célébré pas de la même
manière donc la campagne résonneront
peut-être pas aussi fortement dans le
cas des gens du québec que dans lequel
vivent du canada mais par exemple
l'horreur que tu vécu par les parents
par les enfants elle elle résonne donc
beaucoup de gens comprennent que cette
année ça serait peut-être nécessaire
devant un moment de recueillement
donc vous allez sûrement suivre et voir
la militance au taux du jour du canada
devant les drapeaux du rouge et tulle à
se transformer en orange vous
comprendrez peut-être la raison et la la
la la douleur qui à la base même de
cette mobilisation et vous confronter au
québec on va sûrement le faire d'une
manière qui est propre à nous et qui va
résonner dans le carde pas uniquement
les communautés autochtones mais aussi
les communautés à l'opt a donc je vous
souhaite une bonne semaine
n'hésitez pas à envoyer des questions je
serai de retour à la fin du mois de
juillet donc si je peux avoir des telles
questions pour commencer l'année pour
comme reprendre justement
le flambeau après les vacances je serais
extrêmement contente dans le savoir de
vous depuis
alors c'est une belle semaine